قال الرئيس الروسي ان العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده تمر بازمه عميقه وخلال
مراسم تسليم اوراق الاعتماد للسفراء الجدد
موسكو قالبوتين الى دعم الولايات المتحده
لما وصفه بالانقلاب في كييف عام 2014 اسفر
عن وقوع الازمه الاوكرانيه الراهنه
التي يعتمد عليها بشكل مباشر الامن
والاستقراره العالميان تمر للاسف بازمه
عميقه وتعود جذور هذه الازمه الى النهج
المتبعي في بناء نظام عالمي جديد الازمه
الاوكرانيه وتدهور العلاقات الروسيه
الامريكيه نتج عن استخدام الولايات
المتحده ادوات على غرار دعم ما تسمى
بالثورات الملونه ودعم الانقلاب في كييف
عام 2014 موسكو لطالما دعمت بناء علاقات
روسيه امريكيه على اساس المساواه
والاحترام المتبادل لسياده ومصالح الاخر
دون التدخل في الشؤون الداخليه وسنستمر في
موقفنا هذا